a rose black - says black conejo pee
and it is what moves us all that is in the
our blood in the right rhythm
the rhythm of the heart and such a master then
people try to put things together and show
our Brazilianness
Let's put it like this through music in the
pace there
The city never me it's the plenary is
in a place that stayed nobody wanted
to be here and nowadays these
attention is focused here
the journey closes but has culture
talent
I'm part of that 20 that takes this
message that the whole world is favela
always these people refer to this
here the favela traffic in mexico being
that's not only that we're proving
This with music, too, it leaves work
artistic if there are many things that
people have to give this credibility
is trying to do this with our
music